the Senate Judiciary Committee pulled
back at subpoena former Trump campaign
chair Paul Manafort to testify on the
Russia probe Manta Ford spoke yesterday
with congressional investigators he also
began producing documents for the Senate
Judiciary Committee the House
Intelligence Committee interviewed
president Trump's son-in-law and White
House advisor that's Jared Kushner that
meeting on his ties to Russian officials
and businessman lasted almost three
hours Republican congressman trey Gowdy
is a member of the House Intelligence
Committee that heard yesterday from
Jared Kushner he also became chairman of
the House Oversight and Government
Reform Committee last month he's with us
from the Capitol good morning
congressman good morning how are you I'm
well thank you I know you and your
colleagues questioned Jared Kushner for
about three hours yesterday did you
learn anything different from his 11
page statement I know we did ask him to
extrapolate for instance there's one
quote where he says I didn't collude I'm
not aware of anyone with the campaign
I wouldn't ask him are you aware of
anyone not with a campaign who colluded
coordinated conspired Confederated with
Russia
he was unequivocal in his answer which
was no to all of the questions on both
sides both the Democrat and Republican
side did you find him truthful you know
I'm not a human polygraph I've been 16
years in a courtroom trying to figure
out whether or not a jury would believe
someone or not and you believe people
when there's corroboration for what you
say for instance Jared Kushner said he
left the meeting in June of 2016 that
the Donald Trump jr. meeting he said he
left shortly after he got there were
there two emails that corroborate that
where he is telling his administrative
assistant get me out of here as quickly
as you can
the most telling email to me was the one
the day after the election where he had
to ask someone what's the name of the
Russian ambassador because they couldn't
remember that ain't very good collude
in' when you can't remember the person
you're supposed to be colluding with
let's turn now to president Trump's
comments about the Attorney General and
Jeff Sessions calling him very weak in
public this is the top law enforcement
official in the United States government
are those comments out of order wrong
well they're not helpful I think that
you oughta praise in public and
Teek in private and you shouldn't make
personnel decisions particularly at the
cabinet level via twitter it's a really
hard job the Attorney General doesn't
work for the president he works for a
blindfolded woman holding a set of
scales it's a really important job that
means a lot to me I understand the
president's frustration attorney general
sessions should have been more
forthcoming with the meetings he had
with Russians during the confirmation
process but this is best discussed
privately between two grown-ups and and
if he's lost confidence in him then
Attorney General Sessions can take the
appropriate steps but doing this
publicly I don't think helps our justice
system you were saying that the Attorney
General should have recused himself
aren't you absolutely it have any choice
but recuse himself now he also should
have told everyone about all the
meetings he had with Russian diplomats
from ambassadors we shouldn't have to
wait on the New York Times to tell so
the president is saying that in fact the
Attorney General that I'm planning to
nominate had told me that he was gonna
do exactly what everybody thinks he
should have done he would not have
nominated him to be his attorney general
which is very strange isn't it on the
front I don't I don't think so if I were
interviewing people for the AG job I
would want to know is there any reason
you can't do the job are there any cases
that you would need to recuse yourself
from I mean listen kid ourselves yes
sessions is not the only person in
America qualified to be the Attorney
General I can name a bunch of people
right now so when you're going through
the vetting process one of the questions
you ask is are there any cases you're
not going to be able to oversee or
participate in and when the answer is
yeah there's a really big one because I
didn't tell everyone about my meetings
with Russian diplomats that's something
I would want to know what happens if the
president the United States fires Robert
Muller he can't fire Bob Mahler you mean
the deputy took a ginger can or the only
person who can fire a Special Counsel is
the Attorney General who is recused
which means it's the Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein sold and
there are a lot of moving parts for the
president to be able to fire about
moment the president has indicated in an
interview with the New York Times that
he is considering this that he has
consulted with advisors that if Jeff
Sessions
resigns or is fired while the Congress
is on recess someone can be put into
that role of Attorney General and won't
have to be confirmed by the by the US
Senate does that worry you I don't like
recess appointments I didn't like it
when President Obama did it I don't like
it when Republican presidents it
circumvents the Constitution and you can
put me in the category of not liking
recess appointments I don't think the
president's going to do that and it
would be a tough rest of his first term
if he began to go the recess appointment
this is a yes/no question should robert
muller be fire no that's an easy I could
give you a two-word answer but it's
family television so okay the first word
begin with a name is NH don't tell my
wife I said that all right congressman
got it rockin the new stubble look is
that a new look for you these days
very nice well thank you you're the
first person to say that and there are a
million that have said otherwise you
know we'll always comment on lawmakers
appearance that says you look good
congressman thank you very much for
joining us today really appreciate thank
y'all what make y'all I like it